- To be a part of something
that people really appreciate,
as much as maybe certain
people hate to admit it,
it's important to us.
Like, it's always, for
me, it's always been
like, the more simple things
in life that I've appreciated.
And to be honest with you,
I feel like too much focus
and I feel like too much
attention is being placed
on things that really are of no relevance.
For me, it was really just an idea.
And as a single person, what's an idea,
it doesn't really mean anything.
What makes it live and
breathe are the people
that subscribe to the
philosophy and the idea that--
- He was an American actor who
began his television career
guest starring in shows
like Touched By An Angel
and The Young And The Restless.
He rose to international fame
for playing Brian O' Connor
in the hit series Fast And The Furious.
He also founded the charity
Reach Out Worldwide,
which was an organization that
helped provide relief efforts
to countries when they
had natural disasters.
He's Paul Walker and here's my take
on his top 10 rules for success.
Rule number two is my personal favorite,
I'd make sure to stick around
all the way till the end
for some special bonus clips.
Also, as Paul is talking,
if he says something
that really resonates with you,
please leave it in the comments below
and put quotes around it
so other people can be inspired as well.
Enjoy.
- I woke up every morning excited.
I was completely jacked,
I'd never been more excited
to go to work every day
as I was on this project.
At the end of the day,
I'd never been more drained in my life.
But somehow, some way, I
found the energy every morning
to get up and just go for it.
And the further we got into it,
the more Wayne was just like
"Okay, do what you want to do,
"do what you want to do."
And I never had that
kind of freedom before.
I enjoy doing them.
But more than that, actually
let me rephrase that.
I think the reason why I
enjoy it so much is because
how much the people get off,
the audience appreciates what we do.
There's a lot of things I could be doing
outside of the industry,
even within the industry.
But, you know, I don't
know if the satisfaction
would be the same.
Because to be a part of something
that people really appreciate,
as much as maybe certain
people hate to admit it,
it's important to us, you know, as humans.
You want to believe that
what you're putting out there
and what you've dedicated so much time to,
there's a certain degree
of acknowledgement.
And more than acknowledgement,
an appreciation.
Obviously, this one's been
appreciated for a long time
and that's a great feeling.
There really isn't a whole
lot of pressure or stress
making a movie like this.
I think the most pressure is
probably felt by the stunt men
when they got to go do some crazy stunt.
Because, man, they're putting
their life on the line.
And there's never a guarantee,
there's always a degree of risk.
But for me, it's more
Just about showing up
and having a good time and
doing the best that I can do.
But I can really only worry about myself.
You know, if it doesn't feel
right, it's probably not right
so let's figure out how we can fix it.
But I just roll with it.
One day at a time for me,
that's the way I live my life,
that's the way I do my job.
Just come in and I try to
do my best, I give it 110%.
- Paul, when you first
signed up for the first one,
which was back in like '99, 2000,
did you think you'd be
sitting here in 2013
talking about number six?
- No, not a chance.
No screenplay, nothing when I signed on.
It was just an idea.
And it's funny because I wanted to do it,
you know, working with my friends
'cause I'd already worked
with these people before.
And they're like "You can't do it."
My representatives are
telling me "You can't do it,
"there's no script, there's nothing."
- You didn't listen to their advice.
- You were right.
- I got lucky.
But it's just, you know,
following your heart
kind of thing.
And it wasn't even about down the road,
it was about living in the moment.
And I got lucky.
- [Woman] To be somebody
who is a daredevil.
But in the same time, very private.
Who doesn't really go
into the Hollywood scene.
Is there something that
we don't know about you?
- Well, I think in terms of
just, kind of reservations
with the whole thing because
I've always considered myself
to be kind of--
I don't subscribe to
what's put in our face.
For me, it's always been the
more simple things in life
that I've appreciated.
And to be honest with you,
I feel like too much focus
and I feel like too much
attention is being placed
on things that really are of no relevance
and just really aren't important.
From the crazy reality
shows and all that stuff
that we have right now.
So you know what I'm talking about.
And so if you're playing in that world
and you're sensitive to
not wanting to play into it
to that degree, there's always trepidation
in every step that you make.
Because you don't want to be
misinterpreted or misunderstood.
People are so afraid to
offend or say something.
It's like maybe if I say
this, I jeopardize my career,
maybe I won't get another job.
I don't want to badmouth
this person or that person.
Personally, I like to be straight up.
If I had some smack or some
trash to talk to about someone,
I'd be tempted to give
it to you right now.
For me, it's really based on,
my reaction is based on the
general public's reaction.
I don't know if I like something
until I know the people like it.
Especially in movies like
this where the people,
the fans, they're very
passionate about it.
The first one was well-received,
the second one was well-received,
and now here we are making a fourth one.
I don't want to disappoint, you know.
There's a lot of fans out there
so if they're happy, I'm happy.
That's pretty much what it comes down to.
- [Man] How is the relationship
when you're not shooting,
are you guys like friends?
- Yeah, we're friends,
and there's times where
people drive me nuts.
- [Man] Like in real life?
- Yeah, in real life.
It happens, I mean, we've been
working together for so long
and there's certain
personalities, I'm like "Really,
"you're still like that guy?"
But you learn to accept
people for who they are
and what it's about.
There's been a lot of self
discovery for all of us
on this too.
I love Tyrese like a brother,
he drives me insane sometimes.
And we give each other a hard time.
But there's always love between us.
Vin, we come from opposite coasts
and we got two completely
different approaches to life,
imagine that, you know.
His childhood was completely
different than mine.
So sometimes we don't
always see eye to eye.
But I think we complement one another.
- [Woman] I understand
you are quite involved
with your own foundation.
You are doing some great things for people
and other people could rally to you
if they knew something about you.
- [Woman 2] How come we didn't
know anything about that.
I just found out you had this foundation.
- [Paul] About what?
- [Woman] About you trying to do that.
- Because it's not about advertising it,
it's about just doing it.
The thing that I like is it's not--
This isn't a promotional campaign.
This is something where
it was just an idea
and a few friends went to
Haiti, that's all it was.
And the Haiti turned into Chile
and then Chile turned
into, I think, Indonesia.
And then that turned into, more
recently, the tornado thing.
And then it was along the way,
that we realized that we
had something that was good,
that people actually cared and
were taking an interest in.
So the idea became a foundation.
It wasn't like "This is the
idea, let's be a foundation."
It was just like-minded friends.
For us, it's a small group
of eight to 12 people.
We go in, we can make it
happen within 42 to 72 hours.
And by the time the
Red Cross comes around,
we can be like "This is
what we figured out."
And now we leave.
And I wanted to remain small
and intimate like that.
It's important, I never wanted--
Nobody wants it, that's involved,
wants it to become this big thing.
Because we will no longer be
effective in our capacity.
And it's like we're not
going to move mountains
like the Red Cross does,
but we're like that
little pebble in the pond.
We really believe if you can
impact one person's life,
one family's life, that
radiates from that.
And so that's the philosophy
and that's what we're
trying to stick with.
Yeah, with Reach Out Worldwide,
things have moved along really well.
Its inception was last year.
Last year alone, I think we
had three or four outings.
We had one this year, we had
the tornado in Tuscaloosa
in Alabama.
But this year, for the most part,
it's been relatively
sleepy, which has been nice.
But what's happened, there's
been a bit of a ground swell.
And organically, what's happened
is we've had different
brands express interest
in potentially sponsoring us
or helping us with our cause.
So the thing that's nice is
we put something out there
that we believed in
and others have jumped on.
Davidoff, for instance,
with their donation.
And since then, STILL, they make chainsaws
and a lot of power tools.
And we use a lot of their
equipment in extraction,
especially in Tuscaloosa.
You can cut in trees to remove debris
and help people gain access to their home.
And it's just exciting,
it's exciting to see what's happening.
So the thing that I like is, you know,
so long as I'm alive and
kicking and I'm making money
and things are going
well, ROWW can continue.
But there's going to come a time where
I might not necessarily be able to fund it
and so to know that
there's outside interests
that are coming in now,
to know that there's a good chance
that this is something that
could potentially be around
well after I leave this
planet, it's a good feeling.
And I think the people that believe in it,
'cause for me, it was really just an idea,
and as a single person, what's an idea,
it doesn't really mean anything.
What makes it live and breathe
are the people that
subscribe to the philosophy
and the idea and the
people that are involved
have just taken it to a
completely different level
so I'm really fortunate.
And the people that are involved
are just really good people.
- Thank you guys so much for watching.
I made this video because Ngiam Tee Ee,
I hope I pronounced
that okay, asked me to.
So if there's a famous entrepreneur
that you want me to profile next,
leave it down in the comments below
and I'll see what I can do.
I'd also love to know what did Paul say
that had the biggest impact on you,
what are you going to
take home from this video
that you're going to
immediately apply to your life
or your business.
Leave it in the comments
and I'm going to join in the discussion.
And finally, I wanted to
give a quick shout out
to Kemo Tedajo, thank you so much
for buying a copy of
my book, Your One Word,
and taking that awesome picture with it
outside the Eiffel Tower in Paris.
It really really really means a lot to me.
So thank you guys again for watching.
I believe in you, I hop you
continue to believe in yourself
and whatever your one word is.
Much love, I'll see you soon.
- Very few of us, myself
included in the few,
on the early trips, I was
really one of the only ones
that didn't have any
professional experience.
And I realized that my
skill set was limited,
so I didn't like that feeling.
As much as I picked up while
we were there and in the field,
I realized that there was more to learn.
And that's a big part of it
that really keeps me drawn
is like, we're only here one time.
And I love the arena, I love
learning about first aid
and anything pertaining to medicine,
it's fascinating to me
so it's one thing I continue to work on
and work towards and work forward with.
And hopefully, within not too much longer,
I'll feel qualified, super qualified.
- [Woman] Who's the
most badass guy on set?
Who's the most, you know?
- Dwayne's the biggest guy.
- Yeah?
- And he's pretty athletic.
I can do the most.
I can surf and I can skate
and I can play volleyball
and do all that stuff,
those guys can't do that.
So it's all a matter of
what you value, I guess.
I race cars, I can drive
better than everybody else.
- [Tyrese] Vin!
Where is he?
Vin!
Everybody's looking for
you in the trailer, man,
I just called your phone like--
Paul, what the fuck are you doing, man?
Dog, what are you doing?
- I'm Vin Diesel.
- Paul, look, if he
see you like this, dog,
he's going to flip out, dog,
you're doing too much right now.
- Diesel time.
Diesel time!
Diesel!
What time is it?
It's Diesel time!
Diesel time!
That's right.
Diesel time, bitches.
- Back in 2002, it was
you, the MTV audience,
that first acknowledged this brotherhood
between Paul Walker and myself
by honoring us with the best team on film.
So it's surreal to be
standing here 12 years later
and that you have been so generous
to give us this award again.
I wish he could be here to see this.
But I know he's here in spirit.
Thank you for honoring me
and more importantly, thank
you for honoring that angel,
my brother, Paul Walker.